welcome back everybody back when they
were teenagers these guys were band
members in real life and on TV they went
their separate ways after the show ended
in 2014 but reunited just a few years
ago and have become a huge success once
again with over two billion Global
streams of their
music you can check out I said billion
that's a lot you can check out the new
deluxe version of their another life
album it's out now please welcome the
guys from Big Time Rush pilot
Jes and Logan
[Applause]
[Music]
Henderson what's up y'all look at that I
am very into this yes I'm a horse guy
yeah I'm I love green too it's my
favorite color you can have it yeah
thank you oh wow it's actually very soft
too um but why reunite now
Congratulations by the way on the second
round
that why did you think now was like the
time to do it well it's been about three
years now actually um it's something we
had spoken about a bunch and over the
years you know the timing with our
personal schedules finding the right
team never quite added up and then we
finally put everything in line it worked
out for us and man we were just so happy
to be back worked out you're selling out
Madison Square Garden The Forum the like
you're you're killing it that's amaz do
you find that what about the fan base
because it's got to be a little
different right from when he first
started as well like do you find that
they're new fans old fans are just a
really good mixture yeah I mean we got
lucky cuz our fans were amazing back
then they're all older now some of them
even have kids now yeah oh so they're
bringing their kids but then the amazing
world of streaming our show got picked
up again so we have have this new
generation of kids so now we go out and
we're in the audience and they're six
they're eight they're 25 they're 30 and
we're like my grandma's also there the
Grandma's there that's grandma boots but
Carlos's kids are also watching it yeah
yeah we got the whole oh that's kind of
cool that your kids are like into it oh
my kids I mean I think I think our our
our first tour back was when they really
were like my dad's cool oh that's a win
man and hold on we did one show and
ocean oh there they are yeah ocean my
oldest he it's actually his birthday
today he happy birthday he runs up to me
and he goes he goes I'm so proud of you
Daddy and I was just like oh my God I
love I would break down I and it's so
cool when you're cool to your kids like
it's like you can win a words you can do
stuff but when your kid looks at you
like you're like Thor you're like oh my
God like it's it's magical so what about
I have to ask CU a lot of artists have
like pre-show things y'all do a quack
what yeah what do you do it's like a
Mighty Ducks kind of quack I love the
mighty dogs yeah there's there's four
four grown men making a quack sound it
just kind of gets you out quackor every
so we incorporate our crew and anybody
who's around we bring in so come on in
hands in right Hands words of wisdom we
ask for words of wisdom I have dry hands
I'm so sorry okay are those words of
wisdom got use more lotion what would
you tell us before a show words of
wisdom don't suck
don't quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack all right all right all
right so y'all been doing that since the
beginning since the beginning every
single show it's good luck we have to do
it yes since
I before don't suck don't suck well
here's my I I kept it family friendly
that's not what I
say I usually am messing with my band
I'll pick like one person I'm like don't
you this up and I'm totally messing with
everyone but it's the yeah it breaks the
ice you know when you get out there so
wait what's the song that you're
performing later let's talk about that
one one of our favorites okay it's
weekends well those are fun they are
they are what a great title yeah what's
it about well first off it's a
song it's very dark kind of about
getting ghosted um but you know what I
love about the song though is that the
way it came about the four of us you
know we live in different parts of the
world so when we get together it's
flying in and we we try and pick fun
locations so we had to finish the album
we went to Big Bear rented a cabin
selfishly um yeah well if you got to fly
anywhere you might as well fly somewhere
fun but anyway this is one of a couple
of songs that came out of that trip and
it really is so so much better for us
when we get to be in the same room to
write music together versus somebody
writes a song then you have to cut it
and kind of make it work and this was
one of those I think it's special
because we all did it together you know
how it is when a song surprises you you
finish it and then when it gets really
done done and then you're like I think I
like this the most yeah it was like a
dark horse you were like I was almost
going to not put that on the album and
this version is our acoustic version
which just came out on our Deluxe album
and I think I like it even better than
acous cuz when you can break down a song
and hear it like that that means it's a
really excellent song and it still
captivates you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
agreed thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home